*Constipated Groan* redtheredgamingonline
*depressing music*
Ah the hard life of a youtuber
*fans cheering* (Oh yeah soso hard)
*more cheering and screaming*
*pewds awkward laugh*
I've been filming ALL DAY (I'm sorry do u need a hug :D)
Can you tell? (damn back up pewds)
*depressing laugh*
Hello?
But i need a video for tomorrow
and I don't have one yet
*awkward laugh*
So I thought we play some horror games (YAAY!!!)
Like the good old days because its so late anyway (why not. AMIRITE)
*depressing music again*
I work so hard
I know I am a hard worker (eh maybe? sort of? i don't know)
Oh but the things I do for my- *intensifies* faaaans
What is wrong with me? (Where do I begin... jk luv u :X)
You can tell I'm tired (ME toooo PEWDS)
Because it's not, i'm not funny, and just fucking annoyed (no ur not pewds ur always hilarious)
Okay lets play this game
Michael has selected these games for me
Thank you Romanian!
Michael: You are welcome!
He says "fuck off" (no he doesn't, don't listen to Pewds)
Can you believe that guy? (jk, ALWAYS listen to Pewds)
'The Joy of creation' (creating wuuuutt??)
Michael, I played this game!
There are other levels (DUUUH!!)
I'm told by Romanian
Well let's check it out (ok)
Aw didn't you miss when pewdiepie used to play horror games?
le epic jump-scare faces xd
HAA
*picture click noise*
HOAH
HAAA
"Wonderful ;D"
Ok actually you know what this looks cool
I'll put- I'll play it
Oh!
Oh! (Shet)
Game narrator: "I see you're in quite the trouble."
Woah this looks awesome
Game narrator: "Who I am is not the problem now."
Pewds: and it's good voice acting
Pewds: I like how i'm jogging like
┌( ಠ‿ಠ)┘
Pewds: Look at dat thumb action (that's what she said XD)
*CLICKING INTENSIFYS*
I gotta destroy that comp- complex
Pewds: I gotta destroy dat clomplex
Pewds: Complex**
SHUSH
Game narrator: "Find and destroy the weakened pipes around the place."
wHOA-WH
oh
WOAH
jESus
Pewds: bonny is like-
Bunny: "one day-"
"I'll sex him" ≖‿≖ (Bruh....Live ur dreams...*slowly backs away*)
Game narrator: "And he doesn't like uh..."
Pewds: He doesn't what
Game narrator: "visitors." (ooooh ominous)
Awe shhhhh...
Game narrator: "Who he is-"
FUck
I'm scared
I'm legit scared
this doesn't happen very often
lets use this
to our advantage
could it be because im playing
during the night (We HAVE A SAVAGE RIGHT HERE!!!)
Heyyy
Hey...ok let's just be careful
jesus
look at my hand
i got parkinson's all of a sudden
Oh my god
No, I hear him (oh u ded) (OHHH SHITE!!)
OH
OH IT'S COMING HERE
Timmy do something! (RIP Timmy Died of....Being A goddamned moron)
Okay, I don't-
EHUGGG
GOD!
(poods r u ok there?) (....Poods?...Rest in Pepperoni's.....;-;)
*emerges from his "hiding spot'* (THE IMMERSIVE POODIEPIE AWAKENS!!!)
MMMMMMMMM
Well done! (Hoorray! You can now move out of your mothers basement! :D)
Fuck that.
*picture click sound* (10/10 Picture Skillz)
*picture click sound*
You know what?
I need...
I need something to calm down.
I need something to feel better.
*emotional/atmospheric guitar music*(RIP Poodiepie)
I know...
i need something to feel better
My favorite videos.
People...
...Eating...
...Cereal.
*click sound* (.......)
it always calms me down
its like asmr for me (..............You....You are...serious...I THOUGHT I WAS THE ONLY ONE!!!)
*milk pouring* (.....)
*milk pouring intensifies* (OH MY...GAWWWWWDDDDD)
ALL RIGHT
I THINK IM READY FOR ROUND TWO
oOOoohh shit
my doge
my snoop dawg-gitty-dawg (RIP My brain cells of logic.I watched to many PoodiePie vids...Shite)
alright so i gotta find
oh OH OkAy here we go (OHFUCKKK)
Damage pipes
Acquire hammer
Damaged pipes
Acquire lighter
Get back to the entrance
Get back to the.. PFFT
*scoffs* PFTT
EASY
Pewds: Mark.
That tea is way to hot to drink.
It's not supposed to steam like that,
You're gonna burn your tongue.
*gasp* JAVLA VA...
FAN...!
Pewds: Mark.
That tea is way to hot to drink.
It's not supposed to steam like that,
You're gonna burn your tongue.
i-is this a branded video!?
i don't understand
i don't
can someone explain?
who lights a candle for breakfast?
don't
don't make me that face mark
i think that what bothers me most about this video
is that he lit a candle
cause guys don't lit candles
its forbidden
just
you can't do that
what are you gonna do next?!
stare at a banana
no
alright i'am ready for more now
this game is clearly wayy
to fucking hard for me
OKAY
okay
i just gotta hide
here we go
*camera click*
alright
*spoops*
bad at video games?
*ZZBLBLE*
*slowmo poods*
*camera click*
"you were close"
MARZIA: You suck at game, I break up with you
bad at video games?
if Marzia was here right now
she would literally
Why is this my life?
What am I doing wrong?
MARZIA: You suck at game, I break up with you
Pewds: Wait no martzia pls I -
WHAT THE-
*LOUD NOISE*
Why is this my life?
What am I doing wrong?
can you help me?
Can you help me, please?
clearly
i need some fucking help
hey this looks different
*gasp* oh my god
its just like the game
Oh! OH
OOooh
Ooooh
OH I GOT IT
I got the hammer
damouge da p-
Hell yeah!!
Hell yea i-
damn it
alright so
aquire the hammer
damage da pipes
damouge da p-
i've seen a shit ton of pipes
this is easy
We can DO this!
are you with me right now?
theres a pipe
alright so
*clank*
*GASP*
We can DO this!
are you with me right now?
I got a great feeling
aw fuck
i just walked in circles mate
*GASP*
NAY! NAY!
aAHGGG
NAAAAAY!
AUUGH
RUNN
RUUN
Agh...
My cereal!
*camera click*
WoNdErFuL!
aAHGGG
*relaxing elevator-esque music*
I'm ready for more (Confident Pewds)
AUUGH
JESUS!!
*spills cereals*
Agh...
My cereal!
*camera click*
WoNdErFuL!
i get it now
i get it
what can i say
you converted me
*nom*
Romanian, whats the next game?
（ミ￣ー￣ミ)
He said this one
now what the fuck is this?
Game: *moans creepily*
WHAAT WAS THAT???
is someone-
what
Man my cereal just flew out of my bowl, man.
the
fuck
Ya know,
You know, not that one.
Not that one...
Game: *moans creepily*
I'm not doing that o-
I'm not doing that one ●_●
*lightning and thunder* OH Javla...
HOLY Fuck!!
Man my cereal just flew out of my bowl, man.
What is wrong...?
*JUMPSCARE*
*SPOOPED*
Ya know,
ya know
You know, not that one.
Not that one...
im not
I'm not doing that o-
I'm not doin' that one
I'm not doing that one ●_●
For four...
Fucking...
*heue*
-chuckles-
What is wrong...?
oh
i think this
is probably my favorite
channel on youtube
You... f-
and smiles
he sits and smiles
For four...
Fucking...
JESUS
Hours
WOAH
SHIT
JESUS
SHIT.
You... f-
OHHHHHH - ! (Shocked Pewds)
TWO HUNDRED
THIS IS TERRIFYING!
PARTS??
TWOOoo
HunDREEdd
WOAH
*BURPS*
uhggg
JESUS
SHIT.
WHAT THE
FUCK
well the game is
over here... for some reason,
WHAT THE
SHH-
WHOA
OOH
*BURPS*
uhggg
-burps then says uhhh-
that is not okay
(smh)
Why is it over here?
alright
well the game is
over here... for some reason,
so -
I'm not ignoring you.
im just-
the game is too-
aHHhhh
im getting to old
for this maan
im looking ov-
im not ignore-
calm down
Its ok.
heyyyyy
hey don't make that face
nooooo
its
i have
three screens *sigh*
ohH
OHh
time is tickin'
time is -
in the WOODS
THIS
IS
REALLY
WEIRD
alright
hey
i got that thing
*inaudible* can happen
i can't
OH
i can't see
im gonna
im g-
its slender *flashbacks*
its sle-
That's embarrassing...
;w;
i gotchu
just need eight more
eight more then i can go home
annddd
UGHHHhaaa (Pewds ducks)
UHEUGH
Nay...
NAY.
HeLlO tHeRe
Oh no you saw me
ohhoho
oooohh
you saww meee
That's embarrassing...
;w;
ohoh
i caan'tt
bumb
Meh
nOooo
you weren't supposed
to see that
*jazzy music*
HeLlO tHeRe
*Sigh*
OOh
Oops
*pfst*
OOps
*laughs*
*facepalm*
ughh it's embarrassing
you know what its late
i'll play
one of these properly
another time *-*
but I
im realy tired
*eghnom*
i just wana
i just wanna-
i just wana go to sleep
i wana go to sleep now
I'm probably gonna
I'm gonna probably gonna go home
have a quick wang
and have a quick wank ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
watch this video
and then have another one
so thank you for watching
*casual cartoon music*
*gasp*
GOD!
*click sound*
*milk pouring intensifies*
*gasp* JAVLA VA...
FAN...!
*relaxing elevator-esque music*
NAY! NAY!
NAY!
NAAAAAY!
*lightning and thunder* OH Javla...
Nay...
NAY.
UHEUGH
*casual cartoon music*